freshly dug unmarked grave in a cemetery
in the center of Bangkok the local
Muslim Community was called on Sunday to
collect the body of a man who died two
days before
his name was matati met koban an ethnic
uyghur from xinjiang in western China he
was a uyghur refugee one of a group of
men who've now spent nearly a decade
detained in Thailand without rights or
representation he'd been trying to get
to Malaysia and a new life when he was
arrested in Thailand and held at
bangkok's Infamous migrant Detention
Center conditions are known to be
crowded and unsanitary but the few
people who have regular contact with
uyghur detainees say they're treated
particularly poorly in their complaints
are ignored
all different like health problems
mom got the kidney some got the heart
some got the high blood pressure and
some got the diabetes
some got the cancer protists erupted in
Turkey when Thailand forcibly
repatriated 109 week refugees in 2015
after Chinese diplomatic pressure those
who remain in Thailand have been in
limbo ever since the ties are caught
between the Chinese and an International
Coalition that's saying you can't send
them back to China
uh so these people are left to rot uh
you know it's like Thailand has thrown
away the key on this group of weakers
the Thai immigration department has
refused to comment further on the
situation
or explain how five uyghurs have died in
the past five years this quiet little
graveyard in the center of the city has
now become the final resting place for
several uighur detainees There's real
concern for the health of those that
remain in detention particularly as
they've now been effectively cut off
from the outside world
for nearly a decade
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok
Samsung Electronics is reported